this broke me the the dot
over the eye that broke me i'm
i'm done
[Music]
hey you want to talk to god god is dead
god remains dead and we have killed him
who will wipe this blood off us
what festivals of atonement what sacred
game shall we have to invent
frederick nature 1882. we're just trying
to sell you some drugs and you made it
weird
[Music]
hello sir you uh can't show people that
a shirt
oh
[Music]
so that'll be eight hundred and eighty
dollars here's my credit card
why don't you just charge it and keep it
forever and
also here's the keys to my car wait do
you guys have like a take a car leave a
car tray
no yeah just take it just take it
you put the peeps in the chili pot and
eat them both up you put the peeps
in the chili pot and add the m m's you
put the peeps
in the chili pot it makes it taste bad
i'm gonna eat all this chili
and or die trying anyone want any
i'm just gonna put it right down here
come on
dip your balls in my chili scoopy little
mittens right in the stew
professor i can see that you're going
through something but exams are next
week
so can you teach us anything all right
nerd wanna learn something i'll teach
you something i'm gonna teach you the
meaning of life
how you like them apples now over the
last
2500 years western philosophers have
formed three
main theories on how to live an ethical
life first off
there's virtue ethics aristotle believed
that there were certain virtues of mind
and character like
courage or generosity and you should try
to develop yourself
in accordance with those virtues the
gift will be anonymous
next there's consequentialism the basis
for judgment about whether something is
right or wrong stems from the
consequences of that action how much
utility
or good did it accomplish versus how
much pain or bad and finally
there's deontology the school of thought
that there are
strict rules and duties that everyone
must adhere to
in a functioning society being ethical
is simply identifying and obeying those
duties
and following those rules but here's the
thing a little chilly babies
all three of those theories are hot
stinky cat dooky
the true meaning of life the actual
ethical system that you should all
follow is nihilism
the world is empty
there is no point to anything and you're
just gonna
die so do whatever and now
i'm gonna eat my marshmallow candy chili
in silence
and you all can jump up your own
butts
did you forget something what happened
to you guys
give it back
the gift basket give it back what is
this it's real simple
if you don't appreciate what we do then
give us back our basket
maybe you should leave yeah maybe we
should
maybe you should leave come on let's
leave but before we leave
my wet friend and i are gonna wait for
our cabs on your
nice couches can you call us a cab
please i'm gonna
oh sorry look my clothes are so wet wet
nice leather oh my shoes are so muddy
all right here you go take it there it's
been opened
yeah it was mine what's missing
there's turtles where are the turtles
where are the turtles come on guys get
out of here where are the turtles
are they excuse me i have an
announcement to make we seem to be
missing a box of chocolate turtles with
pecans
and we will not be leaving the premises
until we obtain them hand
over the turtles now
i ate them okay i ate the turtles
they're gone
we'll bill you
may i have your attention please this
office
will not be using any new technology
ever starting now
that is not correct ryan thinks
that technology is the answer well guess
what i just drove my car into a lake
you did what i drove my car
into a lake
is uh everything okay santiago no i lost
my
ring did you see where it went actually
it's behind one of these three doors why
don't you pick one
are you trying to monty hall me
it's unbelievable i don't need monty
hall ruining my place of work but monty
hall has already ruined my home life
come on sir
the math thing isn't the problem night
shift's keeping you and kevin apart you
two just need to bone
what did you say don't say it again i
said you two need a bone
how dare you detective
diaz i am your superior officer
bone what happens in my bedroom
detective is
none of your business bone
don't ever speak to me like that again
[Music]
why did you do that dude just pen up now
he knows problem solved
seriously shut those babies up we can't
they won't stop
this is how the world is now the sound
is burrowing into my brain it's worse
than marcus okay that's unfair
unfair i'm the bereaved party here some
traveling pervert
steals my mom's birthday from me and
then has the gray-haired balls
to tell me how to deal with her death
give me the babies just give me all the
babies
stupid thing come on give it to me give
me give me give me
don't worry about it don't worry about
it
[Music]
yeah yep all the babies i'm gonna deal
with this baby problem right now
give me give me give me give me give me
babies
throw it in baby
anthony what the hell where's my baby mr
griffin sort of took it took it where
he took them all or free but i'll get
enough in health
my baby my baby
[Music]
there's no more assignment we can't be
graded on any of this now
all quiet
[Music]
no more grates it's over
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
i vomited somewhere in this room
i don't remember where though wait you
might want to check that drawer
stop pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friend
nothing like a complete physical
breakdown to make a guy seem less
intimidating
i love the flu have you ever updated
your flash player
it is so sad what happens to version
11.4 oh what now
i'm taking hormone shots to have a baby
you son of a [ __ ] a beautiful little
baby
being a woman is the word yeah i'm sorry
trey i don't know where jenna is
i'm sorry i'm late i was busy burning
down a panda express that i had fallen
in love with oh my god
jenna are you okay i'm fine liz
i'm just having a celebrity breakdown
our next guest has had a troubling 24
hours that has the tabloids talking and
her friends
concerned let's take a look thank you
donna lakshmi i'm happy for you and i'm
going to let you finish but i just got
to say
guru bar of karapushwami spelled one of
the toughest words of all time
that's yesterday afternoon here you are
early this morning being asked to leave
dick habits birthday party
that's unfortunate then a kleptomania
relapse ending in orgasm
and arrest it's wow gina maroney has
gone crazy
she sure has said the second guy jenna i
know a lot of people are asking are you
okay matthew i'd really prefer to just
talk about my upcoming project
me running through that window
you